let's turn to key conflicts remember we
talked about two different ways to
assign a key the first were data store
automatically assigns a key value for
you and the second where you can provide
a key name ID that generates the key and
when you provide a key name ID you're
responsible for ensuring that they are
unique for all entities of that kind
this is important because otherwise she
will generate the key conflict that's
right we do not want to cause a data
store key conflict that's for sure let's
see what they are and how we can avoid
them let's go back to recipes for a
moment say for example that we have the
recipe kind that we worked with before
and we want to insert a vegetarian
lasagna entity and a meat lasagna entity
into the data store well if I let data
store generate the keys then it will
make sure to create two unique keys one
for the vegetarian lasagna entity and
one for the meat lasagna entity so two
unique keys but let's say that I instead
want to generate the key from a key name
ID I specify then it is very important
that I can guarantee that those are
Janique in this example it is very bad
to choose lasagna as a key name ID if
both vegetarian lasagna and meat lasagna
would have lasagna sticky name the
reason is that when you insert the first
entity it will get its key based on the
key name ID lasagna but when you later
insert the meat lasagna it will
overwrite the vegetarian lasagna since
it also has the key name slash ID
lasagna so again remember this when you
are explicitly setting a key name ID you
have to ensure that they will be unique
and in our application it is safe to use
user ID because the uniqueness of it is
ensured by the user authentication
system as it turns out this is actually
quite convenient since it makes it easy
to retrieve the profile from the data
store that's exactly the code that we
will add in the coming exercise have fun